welcome back to las vegas now with labor
day right around the corner if you are
planning a fun weekend getaway now is
the time to get prepared so joining us
is travel expert and best-selling author
sarah d'anda with some helpful tips hi
sarah
hi thanks for having me of course i love
any excuse to talk about travel and
labor day weekend is always a big one so
let's talk about it overall what can we
expect travel wise when it comes to this
year's labor day weekend
well labor day weekend is traditionally
a road trip holiday and more than half
of us adults are going to be traveling
over the long weekend which by the way
may sound like a lot but this is a
slight decrease from last year now the
great news about that is for you this
means that you'll see less crowds and
more reasonable rates than in the height
of summer
and i think between a lot of issues with
airlines and travel that way and then
gas prices were high for a while you're
kind of in the middle of what's the best
option what is your advice for people
you know getting ready to do those trips
well absolutely i think think about
cities and road trips so like los
angeles or phoenix for example really
easy for you to get to from the las
vegas area you know of course i'm going
to be a little bit biased based in los
angeles myself but it's only a four hour
drive away the weather is still mild
this time of year and you have
everything from beaches to hollywood you
can stay at the jw marriott at la live
in downtown la which by the way is where
i am currently it's close to so many
great restaurants the crypto.com arena
outdoor concerts and of course you get
an up close and personal view of the
downtown skyline now for something a
little bit different a four and a half
hour drive away you've got phoenix and
you could take time to hike like
camelback mountain visit the desert
botanical gardens and here's a fun one
the musical instrument museum is there
the sheraton phoenix downtown is a solid
choice to stay and it's actually the
largest hotel in the city oh my gosh i'm
happy to hear you say that because i
actually have a trip planned to phoenix
and scottsdale area before labor day
weekend so now i know what to check out
and maybe if you're looking for
something to you know unwind and relax a
little uh i saw in your notes here that
palm springs is that another good
destination
absolutely palm springs is a great
destination and what's great about it is
it's only about four hours away and you
can make it this little desert getaway
the ritz carlton rancho mirage is this
perfect luxury retreat you can start or
end your day with a hike a round of golf
and then you can pamper yourself either
lounging by the pool or of course making
it a spa day
that all sounds amazing and it looks so
beautiful there and even though labor
day is coming up quickly it's not too
late you can still plan a last minute
trip right
absolutely you definitely can and if you
really want to save some dollars take
advantage of loyalty and rewards
programs that's definitely going to be
your best way because again this is not
going to be your last trip so you can
start earning points now for a future
vacation i love earning those points you
feel like you get a free vacation down
the road sarah thank you
thank you so much for all these helpful
tips and we'll be sure to follow along
with you on social media and everywhere
to keep up with all those tips so thank
you sarah for joining us